how do you want to wait uh to the
security of our country is insured
that's what the job of the
commander-in-chief is and you make that
decision not the generals you make that
decision based on an analysis of
understanding how virulent the threat of
radical Islam is and you confront that
threat not just militarily and
importantly not just militarily you
confront it first by being honest with
the American public about what this
threat is this president has sanitized
every defense document everything
there's no the the word radical Islam
doesn't appear anywhere why because we
are fighting political correct we're
trying to fight this politically correct
war and not being honest with the
American public as to who the enemy is
how violently they are and why they hate
us and what we must do to stop Governor
per we know you have difference in